[Music]
I want to get even more romantic with
Nick and explore each other sexually
this season's bachelor villain Corrine
is on Wednesdays episode of The Ellen
DeGeneres Show and she has this to say
about her mischievous behavior on the
ABC show watching back I'm funny like I
think you are you're very entertaining
I actually really laughed very hard at
myself I was a little bit more
promiscuous than I thought mmm-hmm when
look would you say that's a great
representation of yourself um that is a
real me it is definitely a real side of
me um but there are many other sides
this is to me I think that you'll see a
lot more of Corrine as the season what
why do you mean that clothed okay
Kareem also played a little game of
who'd you rather her final choice just
might surprise you did you rather Chris
Harrison or Zac Efron I'll have to go
with them
Zach ever I li what's the politically
correct answer here Meg those glasses
are super cute yeah Nick Snickers Drake
Nick you were forming a D in your mouth
you had a D in your mouth
[Applause]
[Music]